in the world of comic books you have
these characters who operate in a world
that's either black or white an
anti-hero kind of lives in that gray
area
does the things that we've not typically
seen from Heroes
it's the things that they won't do to
get the job done
I like characters that walk that fine
line between doing the right thing and
doing what needs to be done
[Music]
Black Adam will bring the bad guy to
Justice Black Adam Justice
foreign
is a hero to his people of conduct he's
their champion
safe conduct no one will
we're here right about now
I know hero
he's extremely intense but there's a
tone of intensity mixed with levity that
he has not a lot of Heroes who pulled
that off you better not drop those
prisoners I'm not going to drop them I'm
going to drop one of them Black Adam is
a man who is really tortured there's
demons within him there's a lot of pain
behind his eyes
haunted by the loss of what he had
he crosses a particular line where
there's more room for savagery without
accountability
rules don't kill people well I do I know
the power of Black Adam those are the
kind of superhero super villain
qualities that changes the game and can
take the power and turn it on its head
the power to be the destroyer of this
world but you can also be its savior